my name is Fernando reamers I'm a
professor of education at Harvard
University and I chair the global
education group at the World Economic
Forum we have just had a plenary session
the forms convening in Rio de Janeiro
where we discussed how to address the
main education challenges in Latin
America that session will have
remarkable consensus on the urgency of
improving the quality irrelevance and
reducing the equity gaps in education in
the region and this is very important to
do to promote economic competitiveness
and also to promote social inclusion and
democratic governance we are living at
extraordinary times of unprecedented
opportunity to use technology and to
foster innovation to cause very positive
disruptions in education that would
allow much greater opportunities for
each student to develop their talent to
take a much more central role in their
education to transform education systems
so that they are much more
student-centered project days so that
they develop in the 21st century skills
the ability to take initiative to solve
problems to work with others in
innovative and in creative ways and in
our panel one of the points of consensus
was the importance of promoting
innovation documenting and disseminating
innovation so that they can be scaled up
and in fact disrupted ecosystem of
education
we agreed on the importance of building
a social movement for education that
brings together members of civil society
political leaders and business leaders
and we agreed on the sensuality of
building productive partnerships on
behalf of education we concluded our
part our panel inviting every member of
the audience to ask three questions the
first one is what am i doing to help
this region advance the education
reforms that are necessary so that every
person in this region has the
opportunity to develop their Colin
second question is is that enough and
third question is what is the next step